comment est-ce que ça va aujourd'hui on
film avec trois smartphones on a ici le
Google pixel 7 Pro on a ici le Galaxy
S22 ultra et on a le site l'iPhone 14
pro max l'idée c'est de faire un test
pour vous guider savoir quel smartphone
choisir entre ces trois s'il vous
intéresse alors on est ici aujourd'hui à
Amsterdam on va faire toutes les photos
avec ces trois smartphones on va les
comparer face à face pour voir ce qui
fonctionne entre le mode portrait entre
les photos normal entre la selfie et
compagnie on fait aussi de la vidéo on a
manqué qui est en train de filmer ici
avec lui on a lui là et moi je suis
juste ici comme ça alors je triche un
peu j'ai mis une petite bonnette
anti-vent je vais essayer de pas
l'utiliser au montage c'est juste pour
avoir une sauvegarde parce que il y a
quand même un petit peu devant ici pour
pas être emmerdé on se fait un tour
complet on regarde on compare ces
smartphones et vous me direz-vous ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire et si l'un
de ces trois smartphones vous intéresse
a bien évidemment vous avez tous les
liens en bas dans la description vous
êtes prêts vous êtes prêts vous êtes
prêts alors on y va
donc là on sera un petit comparatif
vidéo au niveau des smartphones là on
est sur l'iPhone là on est sur galaxy
S22 ultra là on est sur le pixel 7 Pro
on est à Amsterdam on peut regarder
alors on fait les photos on se fait les
vidéos comme ça on peut venir voir ce
qui va bien est-ce que ça va bien d'un
côté l'autre est-ce qu'il réagissent
exactement la même manière est-ce que
l'audio est bon sur un smartphone sur
l'autre c'est bien parce que c'est
important d'avoir cette vision
d'ensemble pour savoir quel smartphone
acheter il y a effectivement la photo
qui est un élément important mais il y a
également toute la partie vidéo là on
est en train de filmer en 4K en UHD à 30
images par seconde on va pas mettre du
60 images parce qu'on peut pas venir
faire des ralentis du 24 ça sera rien du
30 c'est très bien comme ça vous faites
votre propre idée pour voir quel
smartphone marche le mieux entre
l'iPhone 14 pro max Galaxy S22 ultra et
le pixel 7 Pro voilà dites-le moi dans
les commentaires lequel vous préférez
de retour au studio je vous montre
toutes les photos on va les mettre face
à face celle prise avec l'iPhone 14 pro
max c'est le prise avec le Samsung
Galaxy S22 ultra et cette prise avec le
pixel 7 Pro alors vous allez voir c'est
extrêmement intéressant pourquoi parce
que ça va être compliqué de venir
trancher on va essayer de sortir une
tendance générale les trois appareils
réagissent différemment regardez
directement on commence par les photos
de nuit là on est sur l'iPhone il y a un
côté un peu plus terme par rapport
notamment aussi sur la partie du toit
que ce qu'on a avec le Galaxy S22 ultra
et que ce qu'on a ici sur le pixel 7 pro
et il y a une grosse différence aussi au
niveau de la colorimétrie c'est pas du
tout la même chose dans smartphone à
l'autre je trouve ça néanmoins quand
même assez intéressant parce que si vous
regardez au niveau de la gestion des
lumières juste la gestion des lumières
ici elle est très bonne au niveau des
petites ampoules qu'on va retrouver sur
l'iPhone sur le Galaxy c'est aussi pas
mal du tout ça marche vraiment vraiment
bien par contre le pixel il s'en sort
pas bien ça j'avais déjà vu je vous
l'avais montré dans mon test toute cette
partie là elle est pas terrible il
galère un peu plus donc là ce que je
vais préférer un peu c'est la photo du
Galaxy S22 ultra par la colorimétrie par
la gestion de l'image je la trouve un
petit peu trop jeune limite vert quand
même sur l'iPhone c'est un peu différent
au niveau du pixel mais celle que je
trouvais plus sympa et un peu plus
chaude c'est effectivement celle-ci que
j'ai au niveau du Galaxy et notamment au
niveau de toutes les lumières en
arrière-plan vous voyez c'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus terne ici sur le sur
l'iPhone on voit un peu moins bien les
reflets sont moins saturés moins colorés
c'est beaucoup plus flatteur ici sur le
Galaxy et sur le pixel bon c'est aussi
un peu en dessous on continue ici avec
une autre photo à l'intérieur ici c'est
le côté un peu rouille qu'on va
retrouver notamment si jamais une fois
de plus cette colorimétrie au niveau du
Galaxy on a vraiment côté rouille très
naturel on a du détail alors sur le
visage c'est un peu moins bien géré je
vais trouver ici que le pixel est quand
même pas mal je vais préférer je pense
dans pas une vue générale le pixel on
retrouve le côté rouge qu'on a pas
réellement ici sur l'iPhone du côté du
pixel c'est quand même pas mal l'iPhone
c'est un peu plus terne ça reste joli ça
fonctionne mais c'est un peu moins bien
alors photo suivante ça commence un peu
à bouger bon le cadre un peu bouger ce
que je n'aime pas ici c'est celle du
Galaxy S22 ultra j'aime pas du tout la
teinte de peau voyez elle est pas très
jolie il y a un truc qui est très
bizarre je trouve au niveau du pixel
c'est je sais pas pourquoi il me faut
avoir un très grand front que je
retrouve pas ailleurs pourtant c'était
pas très déformant pour autant et là ce
que je préfère c'est vraiment celle du
de l'iPhone ici que je trouve assez
homogène en fait de tous les points de
vue se trouve beaucoup plus joli
beaucoup plus efficace donc l'iPhone me
va bien petit défaut vous allez voir que
qui ressort beaucoup ici sur le S22 on
l'a pas trop encore ici c'est des bruits
dans le ciel vous savez ils ont sorti la
nighthologie je crois saute toujours et
des fois ça marche des fois ça marche
pas trop dans l'ensemble celle que je
vais préférer dites-moi d'ailleurs pour
vous s'il y a un truc qui vous intéresse
qui vous interpelle marquez moi le Time
Code et dites-moi à quel endroit c'est
ici c'est vraiment pour moi sans
conteste celle de l'iPhone je sais pas
pour vous dites le moi en bas dans les
commentaires la photo suivante elle est
super super intéressante regardez sur le
Samsung c'est vraiment le truc que j'ai
reproche ici le ciel ils veulent
chercher à venir trop le pousser pour
qu'on voit le détail pour qu'on voit
plein de choses et je trouve qu'en fait
ça fonctionne pas il y a beaucoup de
bruit ici c'est pas terrible pareil au
niveau des des reflets dans l'eau je
trouve ça pas très joli j'aime beaucoup
par contre ce que nous propose Apple il
y a du détail c'est joli c'est un peu
plus chaud le ciel et noir parce qu'il
fait nuit voilà c'est normal et on
regarde également le pixel c'est pas mal
alors le bon problème du pixel ici c'est
que les reflets ils sont beaucoup trop
tard sont pas vraiment bien les reflets
sont pas trop mauvais sur le Galaxy mais
celui qui s'en sort le mieux ici dans
cette situation c'est sans conteste et
sans appel l'iPhone haute photo on est
toujours sur les canaux à Amsterdam le
pixel est quand même très très bien avec
ici le ciel les petites étoiles qui est
très jolies alors le ciel du Galaxy S22
ultra beaucoup moins bien il y a du
bruit on voit que l'algo cherche à
pousser des choses qui ne ressortiront
pas et c'est un peu trop poussif ils
sont et un peu trop fort j'aime pas trop
l'iPhone ici je trouve un petit peu trop
jeune vous voyez on le voit notamment au
niveau de la coupole ici ça doit être
probablement une église le ciel est pas
mauvais mais il y a une teinte un peu
trop jeune un peu plate en fait je
trouve ça manque un peu de relief ici
pour autant le canal est pas mal celle
qui sortirait le mieux à mon avis celle
du pixel qui reste très joli sur la
promenade sur le côté c'est beau sur
iPhone c'est pas mal aussi mais je
trouve un peu plus plate la photo de
l'iPhone il y a des choses qui sont
intéressantes aussi ici du côté du
Galaxy mais le ciel pour moi c'est la
disqualifie directement là on continue
avec un joli portrait ici qui a pris la
nuit je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
l'iPhone ok c'est pas mal bon les
lumières ici un peu de mal mais il s'en
sort le pixel c'est vraiment son gros
défaut ici voyez toutes les lumières la
nuit là ça fait le taf Samsung bon c'est
à peu près la même chose j'aime bien les
détails au niveau du visage et au niveau
des lumières sur l'iPhone le mode
portrait marche très bien je trouve ici
c'est vraiment pas mal le Galaxy s'en
sort pas mal on a pas le même flou vous
voyez derrière là c'est pas du tout là
le même effet il y a quand même un côté
très beau cake ici qu'on retrouve sur
l'iPhone et sur le pixel va globalement
ici pas grand chose non plus regardez
une fois de plus intéressant parce que
Samsung cherche à trop rehausser les
choses la nuit le ciel du coup ébruiter
pas ouf alors on voit bien on a
l'impression qu'il ferait presque jour
mais ça reste à la nuit j'aime bien
l'idée de la photo de l'iPhone ou au
respect effectivement le fait que c'est
la nuit que la nuit il fait nuit et je
préfère celle du pixel je trouve quand
même que les ciel sont beaucoup mieux
gérés par le pixel ça fonctionne bien on
a quand même une différence on doit
vraiment au niveau de la matière au
niveau de la colo sur la citrouille avec
l'iPhone ici versus le pixel je préfère
ici les couleurs de l'iPhone mais je
préfère le ciel du pixel bon pour moi
ici c'est l'iPhone qui prend le point
autre photo c'est très intéressant parce
que une fois de plus il faut la lumière
sur le visage marche pas trop ici sur le
Samsung il s'en sort pas des masses sur
l'iPhone c'est pas mal et sur le pixel
je suis très foncé au niveau du visage
donc je trouve que ici la photo qui sera
pour moi la plus réussie la plus jolie
ça va être le l'iPhone alors attention
ça peut être pipé aussi sur le pixel de
par la petite lumière qui est derrière
et qu'on n'a pas vu je pense lors du
shooting mais ici c'est pour moi
l'iPhone qui s'en sort alors autre photo
qui a été pris là c'est pas mal je me
sens bien tous les trois différences de
colo là vous voyez c'est intéressant
parce que comme on retrouve un peu ce
côté algorithmique de Samsung arrive
mieux à récupérer ma doudoune récupérer
mon pantalon et mes chaussures donc on
le voit mieux ainsi de façon un peu
normal alors que sur l'iPhone c'est
beaucoup plus dur je suis beaucoup plus
foncé et sur le pixel également donc
pour moi ici l'iPhone sera le plus
mauvais élève le Galaxy s'en sort quand
même très très bien et le pixel ça sera
le deuxième donc premier ici c'est
Samsung deuxième Google troisième iPhone
au niveau de Samsung je trouve que c'est
pas terrible une fois de plus au niveau
du ciel il y a beaucoup de mal la photo
est flou bon t'as-tu une petite défaut
lorsqu'on est venu la shooter l'iPhone
par contre on sort très très bien c'est
très joli c'est détaillé le reflet joli
c'est maronner ça va bien aussi avec la
colorimétrie qu'on trouve ici sur les
iPhone donc ça marche le pixel est bien
meilleur que l'iPhone au niveau du
détail dans le ciel donc c'est vraiment
lui qui s'en sort le mieux ici je trouve
qu'il y a un côté un peu lisse sur l'eau
c'est assez joli mais c'est vrai que
celle de l'iPhone me plaît quand même
davantage alors après c'est vraiment une
différence de goût de ressenti on voit
mieux les arbres c'est plus joli mais le
ciel est quand même plus joli chez
Google bon après on est sur des flexible
dans un cas comme dans l'autre donc
c'est pas extrêmement évident de dire se
positionner
[Applaudissements]
trop on a ici le Galaxy S 22 ultra on va
essayer l'iPhone 14 pro max donc ici on
filme une fois de plus toujours en 4K on
UHD en 30 images par seconde donc vous
voyez ce que ça donne comme ça avec
cette ultra grand-angle vous pouvez
rentrer plus dans le champ et pour les
plans serré c'est quand même vachement
mieux voilà ça je vous laisse regarder
je vous laisse apprécier une fois de
plus me dire lequel vous préférez juste
en bas dans les commentaires on continue
ici alors là on retourne en pleine
journée pleine journée ça me saoule
c'est joli c'est saturé c'est très
flatteur ça me saoule ça sature quand
même beaucoup beaucoup moins saturé au
niveau du pixel et au niveau de l'iPhone
je dirais on est un peu entre les deux
on n'est pas aussi saturé que sur
Samsung mais on est un peu plus saturé
que sur le pixel après c'est une
question de goût c'est vrai que tout de
suite le Galaxy beaucoup plus flatteur
beaucoup plus clair très joli ça dépend
ce que vous aimez on a bien les détails
d'un côté de l'autre est-ce que vous
aimez le côté très saturé auquel cas on
va aller davantage chez Samsung si vous
préférez les choses plus neutres ici
iPhone et Pixel franchement ça se vaut
on change d'optique on passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle on restera un truc très
saturé également ici chez Samsung pas
déformant ça marche bien le pixel aussi
est très bon ça fonctionne bien le ciel
est joli très bonne gestion des lumières
bonne dynamique ça marche bien on vient
se rapprocher en zoomant légèrement très
jolie aussi je préfère quand même
Samsung et si je souris qui sont un peu
au dessus c'est beaucoup plus clair
alors après il y a une vraie inégalité
au niveau du téléobjectif lorsque je
viens zoomer là regardez là bon c'est
pas tout à fait les mêmes focales je
vais avoir un bien meilleur détail alors
je suis quand même beaucoup plus loin
ici sur le Samsung alors j'ai quatre
fois 30 mais je dirais que celui qui
s'en sortira quand même en termes de
photos au niveau du plus gros zoom on
peut dire ça comme ça c'est quand même
Samsung qui est pas mal quoi que au
niveau des hautes lumières là il y a un
chiffre vraiment quand même alors que le
pixel dont je suis pas au niveau de
haute lumière c'est pas mal c'est
peut-être le pixel qui va s'en sortir
davantage ici on continue notre balade
alors une fois de plus que Samsung ça
sera quand même vachement vachement bien
avec un côté un peu plus clair une
meilleure gestion de la luminosité c'est
beaucoup plus jeune ici chez Apple mais
c'est toujours un peu comme ça chez
Google il s'en sort pas mal ça
fonctionne assez bien je dirais qu'ici
quand même le numéro assez Samsung
numéro 2 Google et numéro 3 l'iPhone sur
l'ultra grand temps je garde ma position
et j'aime bien la Apple j'ai mal iPhone
mais le meilleur pour moi ici ça va
quand même mettre le Galaxy S22 ultra et
avec le pixel qui est vraiment pas loin
derrière on vient se rapprocher un peu
on regarde vous voyez ce qu'il y a quand
même plus clair ici sur la brique par
rapport à ce que j'ai sur l'iPhone et
une vraie différence au niveau de la
colo de façon bon après ici on n'est pas
non plus sur la même focale j'ai
l'impression voyez alors là un petit
contre-jour j'aime bien les contre-jours
ça fout un peu le bordel on garde
comment est-ce que c'est géré c'est un
peu plus compliqué au niveau du pixel
regardez ici la voyez on a une petite
tache rouge qu'on a pas de l'autre côté
sur l'iPhone et sur le Galaxy c'est le
Galaxy qui s'en sort mieux en mieux les
façades c'est beaucoup plus joli le ciel
est un peu plus bleu on est à côté jaune
mais c'est beaucoup trop jeune et on va
pas grand chose ici au niveau de
l'iPhone là un problème aussi gestion de
de la lumière qu'on trouve ici sur le
pixel meilleur en photo je dirais ici ça
va scanner le Samsung Galaxy S22 ultra
au niveau de l'ultra grand-angle
également et bien je vois la même chose
regardez il a beaucoup plus de mal le
pixel le soleil est beaucoup plus grand
on a un contour qui est quand même
beaucoup moins net bien qu'on voit les
nuages à côté que c'est quand même pas
trop mal géré mais celui qui s'en sort
le mieux avec une meilleure mise en
avant de la façade ça reste quand même
le Galaxy pareil on vient zoomer
légèrement le Galaxy s'en sort quand
même vachement mieux c'est beaucoup plus
joli que la que l'iPhone je trouve que
c'est beaucoup plus terne ici l'iPhone
le pixel est pas mal mais voyez il a
quand même du mal avec tous ces
problèmes de de de lumière sur des
contre-jour sur des choses comme ça il y
a coûte un peu éblouissant qui qui
fonctionne pas très très bien on se
rapprochant davantage pareil je donne
l'avantage non négligeable au Galaxy
voyez c'est marrant il y a un vrai parti
pris qui est différent c'est beaucoup
plus terne là c'est pareil beaucoup plus
clair beaucoup plus nette beaucoup plus
de peps au niveau du Galaxy pixel est
pas mal mais c'est vrai que l'iPhone je
trouve quand même un peu derrière alors
on est sur du flat chip donc bon faut
pas non plus être négatif mais je trouve
un peu derrière regardez ultra
grand-angle là l'iPhone là il m'a tout
cramé en haut je sais pas pourquoi il a
pas marché le Galaxy fonctionne bien le
pixel fonctionne bien on est vraiment au
coup d'un coup de là sur le pixel et le
Galaxy une petite différence de
colorimétrie enfin plus c'est plus
saturé plus soutenu au niveau des
couleurs au niveau du Galaxy par rapport
au pixel à vous de voir ça dépend une
fois de plus d'égouts et des couleurs
c'est une question de goût personnel là
pareil de la même manière je préférais
le Galaxy en venant me rapprocher c'est
quand même le Galaxy qui s'en sort quand
même le mieux avec beaucoup plus de
détails il y a beaucoup moins de bruit
c'est plus efficace c'est plus saturé
plus coloré plus jolie je trouve là on
est sur un mode portrait alors je
trouvais par contre ici le pixel il y a
les vachement fort là il y a une
différence de focale mais il y a les
très très fort pour venir pousser les
traits il y a un côté un peu
cartoonesque la voyez un peu Marvel au
niveau au niveau du trait qui est un peu
trop accentué je trouve que les choses
se sont très très bien avec un très joli
bouquet derrière le Galaxy pas trop on
se fait un autre portrait ici le
portrait de l'iPhone est pas mal mais je
trouve un poil un peu plus terne alors
là c'est un peu trop saturé un peu trop
rouge au niveau de la teinte de la peau
du tout c'est un peu moins joli pareil
différence au niveau de focale au niveau
du pixel le détourage reste efficace
partout je dirais que celui qui s'en
sort peut-être le mieux ici ce serait
l'iPhone mais c'est pas parfait non plus
là on joue à mais où est charlie en fait
je suis juste ici au centre je trouve
que l'iPhone est très terne très foncé
fait pas sortir les détails c'est pas
très joli j'aime bien ici là tu as plus
la gestion des hautes lumières du Galaxy
S22 ultra le pixel s'en sort pas mal ici
très honnêtement parce que regardez ça
nous récupère beaucoup plus de choses
sous le pont que le Galaxy nous récupère
pas et alors l'iPhone il est carrément
aux fraises ici sur le téléobjectif
c'est la même chose je préfère le ciel
ici du Galaxy ou du pixel que je trouve
beaucoup plus joli le ciel de l'iPhone
voilà on voit rien regardez c'est ces
sondes ces termes c'est pas très joli
hein très honnêtement alors on va
commencer à se rapprocher avec des
focales un peu différentes une fois de
plus les photos sont assez ternes sur
l'iPhone beaucoup plus pêché au niveau
du Galaxy et entre les deux au niveau du
pixel donc ici je vais quand même aller
plus sur le Galaxy et lorsque je viens
de rapprocher davantage alors bon là on
est pas vraiment à la même échelle une
fois de plus le Galaxy s'en sort
beaucoup mieux avec son zoom qui va
beaucoup plus loin que le périscope ça
va quand même vachement plus loin c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux voyez sur des
choses comme ça on a plus de détails
alors que les autres ils y arrivent pas
à regarder au niveau de la peau il y a
rien du tout là ça reste quand même très
joli et là l'iPhone il est aux fraises
complet on peut même venir jusqu'ici bon
là ça sert strictement rien sur le
Samsung alors là une autre petite
devanture c'est pas mal d'un côté comme
de l'autre une fois de plus j'ai une a
préféré le travail de Samsung ici sur
l'ultra grand-angle on a un problème de
gestion des hautes lumières sur l'iPhone
derrière on voit que ça marche pas trop
trop ça marche bien chez Samsung ça
marche bien sur Google c'est une
question après une fois de plus
d'affinité goût saturation ou pas mais
ça marche bien dans tous les cas on
vient se rapprocher forcément c'est
Samsung qui va s'en sortir le mieux et
puis on se rapproche et il sera
forcément bien meilleur on le voit au
niveau des détails vous voyez là ça
vient tout lisser au niveau de l'iPhone
là on récupère quand même de la matière
c'est beaucoup plus juste et sur le
pixel aussi c'est c'est beaucoup moins
bon ok on continue ici avec quelques
photos ça c'est la caméra de selfie et
bien celle du Galaxy je la trouve très
bonne pas particulièrement de piquer je
trouve pas joli par contre très bien au
niveau de l'iPhone très beau piqué et
très joli et au niveau du pixel c'est
pas terrible ici la caméra selfie c'est
très clairement celle de l'iPhone qui
est la meilleure on est venu chercher
des plans un peu plus près un peu plus
serré tester un peu de la macro c'est
quand même l'iPhone qui s'en sort pas
trop mal ici on peut essayer différentes
photos il y a un peu de matière c'est
pas mal là c'est pareil vous voyez on
vient se positionner là alors là pour le
coup je trouve que la macro elle est
bien meilleure sur le Galaxy sur les
autres photos prises avec un contre jour
derrière et bien regarder ça c'est
intéressant on voit que l'algorithme de
Google est bien meilleur parce qu'il
réussit à reconnaître ma tronche et à
ressortir tout ce qu'il y a derrière
alors que sur les autres c'est
complètement cramé sur l'iPhone sur le
Samsung et bon alors il y a rien de
parfait très honnêtement je pense qu'au
niveau quand même de la peau et de la
justesse c'est quand même l'iPhone qui
s'en sort mais les conditions sont quand
même très très difficile ici regardez je
vous montre une dernière photo caméra de
selfie une fois de plus et c'est sans
appel l'iPhone qui s'en sort le mieux au
niveau du visage au niveau des détails
au niveau de la justesse je trouve que
ça me saoule et quand même en dessous et
que Google est vraiment aux fraises donc
la caméra de selfie très clairement ça
va être l'iPhone ça va être Samsung et
le pixel en dernier voilà globalement au
niveau de ses photos ce qu'il faut venir
retenir ici c'est que je trouve que
globalement la journée c'est le Samsung
Galaxy S22 ultra qui sont sortis à le
mieux sur le grand angle ultra
grand-angle et en allant le plus loin
dans zoomer dans l'image c'est lui qui
sera bien meilleur les photos de nuit au
niveau du ciel ça va être quand même le
pixel qui sera bien meilleur ça va se
tenir avec l'iPhone j'ai vraiment bien
peut-être préféré l'iPhone au niveau des
photos de nuit même si c'est vrai que le
pixel sera meilleur au niveau de
certains détails la nuit je trouve que
Samsung est quand même derrière il est
moins bon et en mode portrait je vais
préférer l'iPhone donc vous voyez il y a
pas de truc très juste si vous voulez un
smartphone qui va être assez équilibré
si vous faites beaucoup de photos de
jour aller chez Samsung si vous voulez
de très jolies photos la nuit allez chez
Apple avec son iPhone et si vous voulez
un truc qui est pas mal également je
trouve que le pixel 7 Pro s'en sort pas
mal mais il y a pas hyper flagrant la
caméra selfie c'est l'iPhone c'est sans
appel donc je trouve que en fait voyez
chaque smartphone à ses avantages ses
inconvénients les deux qui vont s'en
sortir le plus je pense que c'est quand
même l'iPhone 14 pro max et le Samsung
Galaxy S 22 ultra le pixel est pas
mauvais mais il y a encore des choses
bien retravailler et à venir améliorer
voilà en tout cas pour cette partie
photo alors voilà pour cette vidéo je
vous ai montré ces trois téléphones tant
au niveau de la photo qu'au niveau de la
vidéo je vous renvoie à chaque vidéo sur
Youtube que ce soit sur le pixel 7 Pro
que ce soit il y a du bruit sur l'iPhone
14 pro max ou sur le Galaxy S22 ultra
comme ça vous aurez tous les détails sur
l'interface on va encore plus loin là
c'est vraiment pour venir faire ce
comparatif un instant tôt ou contre
photo contre photo vidéo contre vidéo
contre vidéo dites-moi lequel a retenu
votre attention lequel vous plaît vous
marquez ça juste en bas dans les
commentaires puis bien évidemment si
l'un de ces produits vous intéresse vous
avez les liens d'affiliation dans la
description alors là il nous reste un
peu de temps on part dans un peu moins
de deux heures on prend le TA lise
direction Paris c'était très cool et si
vous connaissez pas Amsterdam j'ai
visité la ville parce qu'elle est
magnifique c'est juste hyper inspirant
très joli voilà je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous à bientôt bisous samsum
bisous Apple bisous Google Ciao
[Musique]